good afternoon everybody thank you for
joining me I've just quickly scrolled
through the participants and I see some
people I haven't seen a while and would
love to see again and some of our
colleagues so hello all of you
um I I wish we were here in person but
um this is our current situation I'm
going to give a very short introduction
to somebody I suspect many of you know
which is the wonderful Michael steinloff
so it's not to take up too much of our
time
um so Michael steinloff is a veteran of
many things of Poland in the 1980s of
Colombia in 1968 of revolution of Jewish
Revival and a professor of East European
Jewish history we are here today
um to talk about a very special book
that has just come out in English called
this was not America the book is in a
very particular genre which doesn't
really exist on this side of the
Atlantic but is in fact one of my
favorite genius it's a in Polish you
call it a viviad Jacka the kind of river
interview which is a long dialogue
conversation in fact really a kind of
series of conversations woven together
um generally between two thinkers you
know that turns into a book that's not
in monological form but in dialogical
form and this book goes through a kind
of extraordinary autobiography and at
the center of this is a question about
the Holocaust and polish Jewish history
I will not take up any more time I will
just say that the the book that is
beneath the book we're going to talk
about today called bondage to the dead
was one of the books that had the
strongest influence on me when I was a
graduate student in the 1990s but what
I'm going to ask to I'll tell you how
this is going to go what I'm going to
first ask ask Professor steinloff asks
Michael to do is to talk a bit about the
book how it came to be in the
autobiographical narrative and then I
will prompt him with some questions and
then I would like to save time for those
of you in the audience
um to ask questions the format for this
is that chat is disabled but the Q and A
inessa tells me is enabled so if you
have questions please type them in the Q
a and I will do my best to scan through
them and choose as many as we have time
for and Michael's a very friendly person
I'm sure he will try his best to answer
everything honestly
um okay with that I'm going to turn that
over down to Michael and have him talk
to you tell you a bit about this book
how it came into existence and what it's
about the book is called this was not
America and it's a kind of tangled web
of Polish Jewish American history a a
tangle through
polish Jewish American history okay so I
can't talk about this book because it
refers to another book that was
published 25 years ago and that is
um that is bondage that it did which
um Poland in the memory of the Holocaust
and I have to refer to it
because uh this book arose uh the
current book uh arose as as a direct
consequence of that book and um and uh
so
uh that book was
well we have to put Elizabeth
here Elizabeth my colleague my friend
um who at a certain point
uh some years ago uh texted me
um
um saying uh I've read your book seven
times and um and uh and and then and
then she says um uh it's unbelievable I
love it and it's it's it's it's
absolutely true and at the same time
it's it's so
so this is this is um
and so we decided uh now now that book
um
uh bondage to the Dead
poses the idea that see I was trying to
that time 25 years ago deal with the
fact
that
how do you deal with the fact that that
years that that years or months after
the end of the war people who had hidden
Jews still had to hide them
um what the hell was that what is that
um you know and and uh and so
uh I found I couldn't understand that
and and so I I went to uh the only place
I could I felt I could go to was Robert
J lifted and his notion of trauma
um and he was talking about uh you know
things like Hiroshima and so on
um so uh this notion of trauma
uh was then contested
um by Elizabeth and who said no no no
it's not it's not trauma
um and and so uh we started a
conversation
and that conversation was in was a kind
of uh you know as as uh
as Marcy says it was a viviatric it
covered everything and
um and it covered all parts of my life
too so it was partly it's it's
everything it's partly uh biographical
um and it's partly you know political
it's partly me arguing with her uh about
uh about all of this and about the
notion of whether trauma uh first of all
I mean mostly is is the proper uh word
uh is the proper concept
um for what it is I had encountered
um and she argued no it's not it's not
trauma it's it's it's just it's it's
it's just anti-Semitism basically
um and I can I can you know if people
ask me about that I can I can you know
talk about that a little bit but there's
so many there's many different different
directions to go in and I was it was
exciting to be able to uh to look at all
these things so I'm I'm open to you know
I'll just stop and and uh Marcy I mean
do you have something uh I mean if
there's something that I didn't that I
should have explained right right from
the get-go tell me I'll do it but uh you
know if I'm really open to whatever I
mean you know
maybe I'll just throw a couple things
out for the the audience for the people
who are not already in the midst of this
conversation
um Michael is the child of survivors of
the Holocaust each of his parents had
been married before the war you know
each of his parents you know lost
families you know during the war met and
married after the war as kind of low end
survivors Michael was born in France
after the war they soon after moved to
Brighton Beach he grew up in a Polish
Jewish community in Brighton Beach
speaking polish hearing stories about
the war
um he realizes then Brighton Beach is
not actually America it's something else
everybody speaks Polish and constantly
talks about this war
the little the little environment that I
found myself in as a child was that but
mainly and this is not the Brighton
Beach of today it was beginning in the
70s uh all these Russians moved in and
now every things in Russian here right
this is before
and uh okay and and
[Music]
um
yeah all right so this is childhood in
Brighton Beach you then grow up you have
difficult relationship with your parents
uh that you grow up you go to Columbia
you're there in 1968 you're occupying
the building there are scenes right out
of strawberry statement if everybody
anybody remembers that book you're
revolutionary you move to Seattle you
try to overthrow the American government
with a kind of you know eclectic mix of
marxist and Anarchist and anti-racist
and feminist and yeah and you know and
black panthers
um
you go on the run for a while so you
have this very your generation of 68 you
have a very 1968 experience you're a
revolutionary you're a social justice
activist you go back later you know get
a graduate degree in East European
Jewish history your whole your native
language is Polish you learn Yiddish you
know as a way into this history that was
both yours but but somehow not quite
because your parents come from the
assimilated polish speaking
Intelligentsia and then you end up after
your parents have died you know
relatively young you know in Poland at
the end of Martial law around 1983
coming into this scene of trying to
understand the world that your parents
came from you know in a Warsaw in which
there are not very many Jews but there's
a handful of them who are largely the
children of Polish Jewish Communists who
wanted to have nothing to do with being
Jews who are in the midst of
rediscovering that they are Jews and
this then becomes your entry into Poland
you know and your attempt to understand
this world that that disappeared before
you were born you know but that is not
God Without a Trace because through the
cracks there are constantly things
bubbling up from this world that was
killed
that's
wonderful it's the same War yeah thank
you so this is this is my little summary
of the book now there there are two
there are a few things in the book I'd
like to talk about
um
um but maybe I'll start with the one
that's probably most important for our
audience which has to do with this book
bondage to the dead
um and that book came out in 1997
um which when and it it came out when I
was I was living in Warsaw and I don't
remember how I got a copy in English
maybe you brought me a copy in English
somehow somebody gave me a copy of the
book when I was in Warsaw and it was not
yet easy to get it
that way it might have been you it might
have been Cecile what what year was it
it was it was 97.
it was the year the book came out okay
but I wasn't I don't think well it
doesn't matter you you were there
briefly but various people were coming
back and forth in any case what this
book was about you know it was precisely
the question that I had become obsessed
with after two to three months of living
in Warsaw which is that you know the
Jews are gone but there's an obsession
with them
you know they're gone and they're not
gone and there's not only an obsession
with Jews on behalf of you know a
handful of Americans trying to work
through their identity complexes there's
also an obsession with the Jews who are
no longer there on behalf of polls and
this absence of the Jews and what has
happened to the Jews has clearly deeply
inflected you know and weighed upon
everything else that is happening in
Poland you know and so I I came there in
the 90s and I'm looking at there's all
this anti-semitic graffiti there are
stars of David hanging on Gallows there
are people selling anti-semitic books
and Protocols of the Elders of Zion
alongside you know books about Star Wars
and Polish translation on the street my
favorite was was a pickup truck with its
with his back open and on one side
um on one side was
um
a bunch of of raw meat you know that
they were selling the discounted and and
on the other side was
um
um was what you said
[Music]
um
you know
yeah it was that the juxtaposition was
kind of extraordinary because Poland was
just opening up
yeah on the one on the one hand that and
on the other hand that so you know
it was it was uh it was crazy moment it
was a crazy moment but I was there now
are you talking about 79 now no no I'm
talking about 97. 96 right I'm talking
about 97. you were there much and I got
there it wasn't like that when I got
there uh things were were softer and
gentler and it wasn't until uh you know
it was a very different world
yeah I I got there just as lots of
people in the 90s were kind of
rediscovering that they might be of
Jewish origin that they were that their
grandparents were communist that perhaps
their parents were solidarity activists
maybe their parents even had them
baptized because at that time the church
to to have your child baptized during
the time of solidarity when voitiwa was
the patron of solidarity was a sign of
freedom and now they were discovering
that maybe they really had Jewish roots
it was right when Costa gubert
um who was one of the people who was
important for you when you came in the
80s had started this new magazine
midrash
you know in Polish you know and caustic
caustic was is you know one of the most
important
um underground journalism solidarity
activist um who then after in the 90s
became Poland's most important foreign
correspondent um in Bosnia during the
wars of Yugoslavia good question
um and also one of the most important
actors in the Jewish Revival trying to
understand what it meant to be Jewish
and he there was this magazine called
midrash that still exists that he began
to edit in 1997. they still exist I
heard it closed I heard it it may have
closed I thought it's still last year it
was gone that would be sad in any case
it was basically aimed at closet juice
um and in the second issue there was a
half-page advertisement that said do you
have Jewish
rootsanya you remember this is it is it
a secret you know is it a problem or
have you been afraid to talk to your
husband or wife perhaps your children
and it goes on to advertise a
confidential hotline and it says
exactly exactly it's just you do suspect
you're gay right do you suspect this is
something that you can't uh and it's
amazing again we have to understand
uh you know that that that what does it
mean you know that that being Jewish uh
you know takes that takes that form
takes that the Revelation
um that that one is of Jewish roots is
uh has to be approached in such a crazy
crazy way
it was right after that came out when I
actually went to see kostak who I didn't
even know at the time and said is this a
joke and he said no it's not a joke this
is very serious that we get a lot of
phone calls right and I thought what
what is this about and that's when your
book came out when bondage to the dead
was about it was about what what are
these complexes and layer after layer
after layer
um clearly having to do with a lot of
repression you know a lot of trauma you
know a lot of kind of hints of Freud
here and there there were things that
you were trying to figure out
um why are why is Poland so haunted why
are polls so haunted you know why is
there this obsession with the Jews
um and is it love and is it hate and is
it guilt and was it you know was it
participation or was it passivity or was
it and these are the questions that
seemed to me you took on fearlessly in
that book with an amazing amount of
composure you were just trying to figure
it out maybe you could say a little bit
about what you were thinking as you
wrote it as a true American you see I
was I was that's the only way I know you
how to uh how to approach it you know
being nice to everybody making sure not
to insult anybody
um uh but uh but but trying to to figure
this strange thing out and and and then
I found out and that's partly where the
title of the book comes this was not
America
this is not this was not me uh you know
trying to negotiate uh something uh
something that's easily understood uh
because it's not something that's easily
understood and why um
back then 25 years ago I was trying to
understand why someone who had hidden
Jewish children uh
still had them after the war still had
those children in his Garrett and
wouldn't let them out what the hell was
that you know what is that you know and
and that's that's Insanity in a certain
way but if you're if you're polish not
at all I mean that that's uh that that's
the way how a lot of people had to deal
with this and anyway so that's um
yeah that that's that's the inspiration
for
So my answer back then from Robert J
lifton was trauma
they were traumatized by
what they had experienced what they had
seen
uh of Jews dying
uh and here comes saying nonsense
it's not what it is at all when you tell
the audience a little bit about who else
beat it is
you too
but but it's it's you it's because so
much of the book is about that
relationship there's an academic and
also an artist
um who has written widely about uh
basically of focusing on on um most
often on on anti-Semitism uh and and
um
and uh
the notion that uh
polish culture I mean this is the
opposite of the defense of Polish
culture that polish culture is deeply at
its roots
anti-semitic and there's a small number
of historians and you know them of
course who for whom that is mostly
younger even than Elizabeth uh who's in
her 40s or something but uh so that was
you know that that was uh
uh
a contention a bone of contention
um
this is very harsh
she's very harsh in that oh totally
harsh totally harsh very harsh uh and I
had to cope with that as as I was in
this book and it was all for me it's all
for the good you'll see I mean you know
those of you who who go on for this and
actually used to read the book here
you'll see it at least it's a very
interesting interesting places uh
but um
I had to explore I mean
this one word uh this word trauma
I know it's very uh you you told me in
the recent recently that it's very
catchy nowadays
um and everybody's talking about trauma
well I mean I did a lot of talking about
trauma but
what is it I mean what is it okay I'd
love to you know uh I mean does that
seem like a good place to go because I
have no idea what trauma is but I use
the word all the time
let's let's disentangle I would say so
you were looking at Collective trauma in
this book that the witnessing the
witnessing of people being murdered in
front of you was a collective trauma for
the polls and today people might say
secondary trauma when you're watching
somebody else be tortured you know then
you're like vicariously experiencing
something and the other thing that is
very kind of that is very popular
popular isn't the right word but that we
keep returning to a lot now is
intergenerational trauma which in some
sense your book is about all three of
these things Collective trauma secondary
trauma and introduction
uh you know
once again I found myself by accident
getting into the most you know kind of
uh just completely by accident getting
into the trendiest kind of uh uh moments
uh uh you know uh you're very
fashionable
I'm very fashionable it's nice to know
I'm pretty open so it's nice to be
fashionable still I mean you kept trying
to for me your book was about trying to
understand and for me it was a model of
what historians do is we try to
understand you know before we condemn or
judge or we try to make that imaginative
leap and understand what was this
phenomenon what was happening you know
and you come to this idea of trauma and
elsbiet is like trauma shmama they're
all anti-semites that's right that's
that's precisely correct you know it
isn't there yeah it's uh the root of
everything is
um
and one exchange that we had and with I
forget who it was it wasn't directly
with her but um what um
uh
how could people have done this to
people
right it was like a question and she
said no that's not the question it's
like people did this it's like people
did how could people did this to Jews
not people
and so that for me said a lot that for
me helped me to understand
um and is that too elliptical but you
know whatever I think people can
understand well let me now I mean one of
the questions your book raises and I as
an American you know and as a Jew and
someone who's put spent a lot of time in
Poland you spent a lot of time you know
with your cohort of 1968 in America with
activists for gay rights what's feminist
activists with black activists like you
have a you know you're coming from a
certain kind of Cosmopolitan
International
internationalist sensitivity in which
suffering victimization scapegoating is
not something that happens only to Jews
right that must have inflected how you
related to Poland when you got there
because you're coming from an America in
which racism first and foremost is
directed not against Jews but against
blacks what right and and uh and here
and here it's all Jews so you know uh I
don't know is it is that
um how did your experiences in America
then working with American racism and
trying to understand it inflect how you
understood polish anti-semitism
how did it uh well I thought you know I
came uh believing that that I could you
know transpose these experiences
directly
um
you know directly into the Polish
situation
um that uh
uh
but then then I was told no no no you
this is not uh this is not so uh this is
a very different
um
a very different situation a very
different history a very different uh
everything uh and I came you know kind
of naively with this kind of naive
American uh uh what's that book by by
Henry James where where she comes to uh
right right yeah there's the Golden Bowl
I think yeah yeah you know where where
she just you know I came thinking oh you
know here's another here's another
Freedom struggle
right another Freedom struggle uh and uh
that's the way I have to approach it you
know in a very personal way
um because
you know and then it turned out uh you
know as everything in Europe it turns
out certainly in Poland above all in
Poland uh no uh
uh as they said
there's so many things that are that are
that that you don't get and it took me a
while to to figure that out but but uh
my my you know is that is that is that
reasonable to to say that I mean
that it's that it's a very complicated
question no I found it an enormously
complicated question I mean when I when
I read your book I felt like you asked
all the right questions and you
articulated them so well and you gave
the right examples but in the end you
didn't right there was no ultimate
answer but I and but I I empathized with
like yes that was the right question and
we haven't there's something there we
haven't quite gotten to exactly
exactly and and uh I still haven't you
know I said not you know I'm an old man
now but yeah but has wisdom accompanied
that ever
I mean the Paradox in the book is that
you know you're there as the American
Jew and and elsewhere is a very
self-critical pull and she's gaslighting
you you know through the whole second
half of the book everything you say you
know she's she's like but you can't
really think that or you're repressing
that or you're trying not to or you're
doing something circumlocution so as to
excuse people who shouldn't be excused
and I'm still trying to understand by
the way I I'm uh there's words popping
up that I've that I I'm still learning
how to use uh gas lighting
um you know it's not it's not clear to
me what all that uh you know I finally
come closer to to the notion of trauma
but gaslighting is still pretty far from
my uh gaslighting is new I've only
recently used it but I'm using it now in
the sense of she's she's trying to cause
you to doubt yourself right right
constantly critiquing you in a way that
yeah
I mean you know what else people you
know any any Jewish any American Jewish
comedians you know will will agree yeah
what is this I don't know huh you know
and and uh and she knows you know uh I
had I had a uh I I have an Israeli
friend who was who's uh who was in the
states uh for a while and um maybe you
know him you'll have pillid
um and uh and he uh I went up to he was
staying in a loft way up way up high in
in Chinatown and I went up to see him
and I was it was really hot day and and
I said yo this is this is once it tells
you something about Israeli I said yo uh
I just don't get it I don't understand
any and to which you responded you don't
understand I will tell you
you know there's only one answer there's
only one answer at least
um
so so the other thing interesting in
that story is that you know part of this
story is part of an international
generation of 1968. you know on both
sides of the Iron Curtain and on both
sides of the Atlantic there was there
was an edible Rebellion there was a
revolt against the parents against the
silences and complicities of the parents
um and one of those things that you know
in your case is you have these these
people these parents who are coming from
the Polish Jewish Intelligentsia who are
coming from middle class families they
speak perfect literary polish and they
hate the polls they have nothing good to
say about the polls you spend your
childhood listening to this word voina
voina you know which is interesting
because it's precisely the word in
Russian war which is banned now in
Russia
um in which everything was subsumed
under they have nothing good to say
about the polls they don't want to like
the polls all hated them sometimes you
tell this story in the book where you're
out with your parents on the street
somebody hears them speaking polish and
they're like
compatriots you know and your father's
like ah rodazzi to hell with you like
we're not that runs away and runs away
takes takes his family you know because
you know it's like protecting us you
know let's get away from this person
you know
and and you go to Poland and you go to
Poland to to commune with a Jewish past
but you also go to Poland with an
openness to polls you go to Poland with
a willingness to speak Polish you know
you go pull to Poland with a willingness
language so I've been better years
I was very lucky you know he gave me you
know and they lied they said and so so I
could under so I could communicate they
they see that was the only kid in
Brooklyn in that situation who who uh
could have had an active uh
um uh knowledge of Polish you know all
the kids like me they can understand it
but they couldn't speak it so that for
me why why was that
you know what they told me they told me
so that I could I could speak with my
aunt and uncle in Paris
um the uncle my uncle was the was with
my mother's older brother that survived
um and and that's what they said as you
can speak to and and not because not
because you know it was worthy even in
those worthy language nothing here
that's what I grew up
being told
and you I mean when I see you in Poland
you know I feel like one of the things
we share is we both love Poland not not
because we don't see what's horrible
about Poland but there's a deep love
there there is and a deep attachment
there is
um it's a it's a beautiful place where
people keep asking uh fascinating
questions
and uh you know I mean
who knows there's gonna be elections
maybe maybe who knows keep your fingers
crossed
maybe the good guys will win huh how
much of that reaching out to the polls
was a rebellion against your parents
I'm not sure
I'm not sure uh yeah I mean I rebelled
against my parents in lots of ways I'm
not sure that was that was one uh
because my father was long gone by then
you know he died 10 years before and and
uh and I I'm not sure I'm not sure uh
it was an intense desire to to see what
what the world
see
it turned out it wrong for me personally
I wanted I I didn't want to talk about
the Holocaust you know I wanted to talk
about the world before the Holocaust you
know I went to talk about life I mean
this is the way I I talked back then I
want to talk about life not death you
know I want to I want to you know find
out
um what what this world was about that
that my parents and it seemed like a
fascinating world uh and so and so I
became I became enamored of of of of of
who of dead Jews
you see and people ask me what you know
what is this I mean who
you know everyone has their has like a a
group everyone has someone who there who
their uh uh defines themselves when they
Define themselves against uh
um
and uh
you know I had this I have this uh I I
think I tell the story in the in the in
the book about about uh about people
about uh these these Chicanos uh you
know you want to use the word Chicanos
anymore but that back then we use the
word Chicanos
um uh Mexican Americans
um
who talked about who talked about how
they uh how they uh
they had this they had this land
um that's today uh Northern uh New
Mexico and
um
and there were rather northern Mexico
and and southern New Mexico that that
the the mythical name for it is Aslan is
etla and it's a beautiful concept it's a
beautiful thing and I got really into
that back in Seattle because a lot of
these these people talked about Islam
and then I suddenly realized you know
that Aslan is is like is like is like um
the world that show malaikum
you know because it's at the same time
it's beautiful you know and and and and
and and at the same time it's both
beautiful and impoverished totally
impoverished you know and then who are
these Jews you know what are these Jews
from you know these and it's funny
because that's not who my parents were
of course but but uh this notion of uh
of uh yeah uh
we are Jews uh and this is our homeland
okay and we all have homelands of course
and uh uh but my homeland when I went
back there uh was the Jews it turned out
hmm but you also met you also met some
live Jews
krievsky and Costa gabbard at Monica and
and uh yeah
a wonderful guy uh a wonderful man uh
you know he was head of the Jewish uh
historical Institute for for some Years
anyway
um yeah
yeah they some of these people were you
know I I think they saw me as as as
totally naive I remember Pavel saying to
me at one point uh you know because I I
was I was into running back then you
know and and uh no one you know
dogs on me
uh you know I I would especially I liked
uh in the in the uh was that in the um
the Royal the Royal Gardens what's that
was Yankee I used to love to run through
Roy I love running in Washington well
you were you know I would you know I was
there you know and people would stick
their dogs on me you know
and laughed and they even laughed what
the hell is this guy doing
running
um so yeah
uh
what was that an answer to I I've lost
it oh the live Jews who you met who were
working through what it meant to be
doing yeah yeah so so so Pavo said so
when he heard when I told him about that
he said oh the American wants to live
forever
you know
the American yeah I get it so the
American uh yeah
and what what did you learn from them
how did that group of people who were
connected to solidarity who were
carrying out a Jewish Revival who did
not grow up in that Jewish specifically
traditionally Jewish milieu and we're
trying to discover it as adults what did
you learn from them
well learn from them I mean they were
just like me you said because I think
you know I I didn't grow up speaking
Yiddish
you know uh I I I wanted to have I
wished I had
um so in a certain way that that brought
me very close to them
um
and on the other hand you know they were
they were digging they were digging uh
and they were they were creating
something uh new and that was that was
really uh that was really extraordinary
um
you know
I mean
what did I learn from them you know
it's hard to answer that that that
question you know because they were a
certain kind of mediating Bridge there
were the dead Jews who you never met
there were the Jews in Brighton Beach
who you grew up with and then there were
these these Jews who were your
generation who you were encountering in
this place where had things been
different you might have been them you
might have grown up there oh easily
easily that's right that's right so I
don't know uh
I could have been them but I also could
have could have grown up in Israel you
know uh my my father had tickets uh to
to go there I mean he was given this guy
gave him you know and he my father
thought sure should we go we won't go I
mean you know I sometimes consider my
life you know just being
just
if only if only you know the the this I
mean not only did I not have a Homeland
uh but
who wasn't
who who were these people you know uh
they were polish Jews but they always
could have been Israelis I mean
in that way you know
um anyway I think I'm yeah does that
make sense
it does and you've spent a lot of your
life
you know working through a relationship
with a brother who died before you were
born
yes
why don't you why don't you I'll let you
tell the audience this story
the story is uh is a story it's uh it's
uh my father uh had the the
extraordinary Good Fortune you know uh
you know Jews love irony these so are
there a good fortune uh to have gotten
married in uh uh at the end of 1939.
in Warsaw
um
and shortly thereafter uh you know they
may immediately met a child uh
uh he and this woman it is not my mother
I mean you know he's this woman and uh
um
and
as far as I can tell at the age of uh uh
this this boy uh Mikhail they called him
but there's all these different words
because he was named after my
grandfather moisha uh as was I
um
or was he named after him that was never
clear
um but at the age of roughly two and a
half
um he was killed he died
now it was El chipieta who helped me uh
really understand the most probable way
he died
and the most probable way he died was
there was there was there were they were
hiding my father was gone my father was
not in their hiding place and we're
talking 19 you know talking in 1942
right uh after July after the accident
and all that
um
and uh so
how did this happen well most probably
of course who knows uh you know they uh
they're in a hiding place and and the
child who is about two and a half uh
made some sounds you know and and his
mom was holding him and uh his mom
killed him his mom smothered him uh that
was a documented
um you know
there's enough documentation of stuff
like this um
uh to make that the most probable
although not you know some Nazi could
have grabbed him and smashed his head
against the wall that's possible too
I've thought of that sometimes and you
know uh not nice
and uh at a certain point
okay you told me you won me against the
book
uh at a certain point late you know in
uh
in uh in my life I'm relatively late I
was uh I was living uh my friends were
were printers uh who printed for the
Revolution and uh and I was staying at
their place uh on the Lower East Side
and uh
I felt that that uh that uh inside me
was was something strange was was uh was
something that I have to understand you
know the books you know did books are
there their demos and their books
there's a nice typic of the of the play
uh you know of the of uh
you know but then there's uh then
there's bad books which which what they
usually are like I I read about one
difficult someone asked him why did you
come back uh well I came back I came
back that you know I had to come back
because because I slept with boys you
know and uh you know so there's usually
something except in the play there's
usually something bad uh associated with
there that they have to redress
and uh
how do you address a two and a half year
old child
and that's what I experienced I
experienced
rage
rage because because you know why did
you do this to me how did I die you know
uh what was this
what was this
uh and so you know and it was in my
belly kind of this kind of turning this
kind of turning and uh
yeah turning's weren't really the best
word for it I I you you told me not to
but I'm talking about but I'm done I
think I mean it's uh it's very very and
it
um
it pursued me I mean he pursued me I
mean for a while uh
I guess it was it was a sense of uh
uh you know so why did you you know why
why did you mean plural why did you do
this to me why how did this happen you
know and it's like this rage this kind
of
this kind of
you know two two-year-old rage
you know but that might be like I mean
you have kids I had kids
two-year-old rage uh
because you killed me
anyway so there you go and that that
came out of and that's enough that's in
in this book too
there's a lot about him in this book and
I was at the performance in krasnogruda
that maybe which was extraordinary maybe
you could tell the audience about this
kind of musical artificial resolution
yeah that was that was what what sent
him
back to wherever he uh that performance
I mean was was there was this
we created this performance with the
what's what's the with the eye and this
what's his name what the musician what's
his name
um
no it wasn't Michael yeah no it was
someone uh
oh he's wonderful he was a wonderful I
know you know who you're talking about
I'll I'll look it up you keep talking
yeah all right but but anyway
um and the two of us uh he did the music
and I did and I did the
various texts that I dug up
um about about the
about trying to uh
try to deal with this uh with this debit
memory and
um
and uh we it was like a performance we
did that personal gurudi and uh
and oh what's his name he still
performing he's a wonderful musician
um he's a solo guitar player uh among
other things uh
and uh
so anyway this this performance at
krasnagruti uh krasna greedy that we
just is a wonderful isn't a magical
place in the far north east of Poland
where uh
uh
magical things happen and uh and one of
them was this and and they have you know
they they bring people together uh to
talk about the stuff we're talking about
partly but years and years later than
than you know this than what we've been
talking about here
um but anyway that years and years later
is what allowed me to let go of uh or
maybe or maybe he uh allowed himself to
let go no it's maybe you know but but
something happened yeah I I'm no longer
possessed thank goodness
but you were very empathetic to that
that possession or that intimacy I mean
a two and a half year old come on
I mean what am I supposed to you know
curse him no he it's enough that he
cursed me you know
no the else beaters you know probable
scenario
hey where are you hey hey hey
a
technical technical
are you back yeah I'm here hey yay oh
okay uh what was it what was it gonna
okay so no the the scene of the death
because I mihil govinski who is another
who is a child also in the Warsaw Ghetto
um and wrote wrote a book around the
same time in the 90s Chinese which I I
then translate into English and there's
a scene he describes you know of of a
baby in a Cellar where everybody is
hiding they don't want to be taken for
the deportations the baby keeps making
noise people are saying you have to
smother the baby otherwise we're all
going to be caught I used that scene in
my undergraduate seminars and I say what
you know what are the ethics of this
situation do you smother the baby you
know if this there are no innocent
choices in this scenario no of course
not and you do but I have to say my
situation was even tougher because this
was not a baby okay this was you know a
kid who already knew some language
you know
so that that's I'll just add that and
and
um
[Music]
yeah
and you say in the book that when your
first son was born you policed his birth
so that there would be no further I was
with my wife uh who was uh
you know we were to get I mean we were
together she was she was giving birth
and I was watching over her
and um
and she was out of it you know she she
you know she's had him this child is is
coming out uh this baby is coming out
and uh
and I did something you know I just
wanted to I just wanted to make sure
that uh that there was no that there
wasn't anything around us going to grab
into him you know because because that
would be a logical thing uh typical you
know moves out of me and goes into goes
into my my son
um I said I did in this little ritual or
something I don't remember really right
but that was that was a concern of mine
he said you're not getting this one
you're not getting this one uh-uh
so this is I talk about generational you
know yeah
and this is Generation yeah
no a lot of I mean a lot of our
questions now about what led to this
anthropological catastrophe in in Russia
have kind of gone back to
intergenerational trauma the kind of the
idea of things that were not processed
that were not talked about then right
that keep like
experiences under stalinism that were
that were silent that one generation
passed On to the Next Generation
there's nothing I mean that's going on
in Russia Today that can compare to what
happened on the staliness you know it's
it's not it's not proportional it's not
it's not right no I mean
three million was it three million
people start it's three million
ukrainians starve to death purposely I
I think that you know but anyway that
that uh the idea is that what is not
somehow worked through or spoken about
or that there's some kind of
intergenerational transmission of trauma
you know okay that that's that's been I
think where a lot of the discussion is
we're we're running out of time but I
want to get to some of the questions
um you know one one of them the the
first one from Alexandra um color jayska
um I think I know the answer to but I
will let you answer it was it possible
to detach the personal and generational
Trauma from the academic aspect while
you are writing and researching books
did you feel like you could somehow
compartmentalize your own biography and
your family relations as you were being
a scholar in Poland
short answer no
this you know I could discuss stuff I
mean there's more there's more to it
obviously but uh
but no uh
I mean part of
I mean my being in Poland was all about
you know going where my parents had been
I mean and and feeling the feelings and
and
you know uh
for example
that that's where I mean that before the
war not Lefty that today is not the
fever before the war now was where uh my
mother's uh uh lived where my mother
lived and and where where they had their
their business and and I would go you
know I would yeah you know the addresses
are all screwed up so so but but I
wasn't
um yeah
hmm
you see because originally I went to
Poland to to to work on Yolanda parrots
uh no and and uh uh the great you know
uh Yiddish uh Yiddish writer the great
year Sage
um and I dropped that because I thought
I needed to write about Poland and so
um anyway
oh okay I
um um no who was the the musician you
wanted to talk at you like this this is
this this is this is hearsay from
somebody no no that's who I was thinking
of too with Rafael I think it was I
think it was Rafael Robert waginski at
that performance in krasnogruda
oh is that who's Who's Talking Now no no
no somebody else somebody else wrote in
questions that that was the name of the
musician yeah no that's that's the
person I have and I'm thinking of course
and I sure wish he was out there but I
don't think he is yeah no I don't think
he's on Zoom right now but no this is
what this is the name I also forgot but
I know I can't praise him I mean he's a
wonderful guy
no it was extraordinary okay let me give
you let me give you one more question
this is um this this is a question about
their other children of survivors who
grew up hearing you know never again and
the polls are anti-semites you know and
that's a graveyard is there how would
you speak to
other other children whose parents were
survivors or grandchildren of survivors
should they go back to Poland how would
you encourage them
let go let go of all your of
all your hatreds you know really I mean
you know because because people like me
were instructed in hatred uh of polls
I mean
uh
and uh no uh it back look back when I
was in Poland it was it was it was a
place that was a little easier to like
Poland of today yeah
so you know with it so with this
right-wing Nationals everything
um
but uh
yeah
but but you will find you go to Poland
you'll you'll find people you can talk
to but and people that are fascinating
yes
I mean now there's a right way in
government but it's still a divided
Society there's still that like there's
still that half a bullet half well it's
not see what I what I explained to
people is that it's just like us right
exactly right but there's more the bad
guys and here there's more of the good
guys
yeah the percentage kind of like right
yeah the the percentage is a toxic for
discussion but we could also like ask
look at how Poland has taken in
Ukrainian refugees it's a moment yes yes
absolutely yeah absolutely I mean it's
it's uh God it's beautiful it's
beautiful and then it shows you know and
then you know every now and then you
know because I have I have a a black son
uh every now and then you know I think
what if they were what if they were
African
oh oh quickly but that's that's here or
there but you know and you brought him
to Poland what you brought your son to
Poland
yeah but uh
uh it's not exactly a place for for him
yeah
not especially not now
um
no
um so many my life so many there's so
many pieces of my life that are
unintegrated still that that uh yeah
[Music]
we're we're just about out of time but I
want to I want to give you a chance like
having gone through this it's a
remarkable book I want to recommend it's
it's very easy to read it's very
conversational you know it's not you
know there are there are scholarly
references but it's not stilted in
academic you know it's it's very kind of
contestatory you know and passionate in
places but it's also it's about
searching for a way forward you know and
it's about trying to trying from all of
this trauma you know to see is there you
know is there a light is there a way
forward is there a way we can understand
that's where that's that's where that's
where my my origins in the 60s come
because nowadays people everything's
darker you know and for the young people
too uh and that's so sad because back
then it had to get better and what's
more you were there to make sure it's
gonna get better that's what the 60s
were you know and and uh and today
that's that's uh
it's problematic that kind of attitudes
um yeah but I was I was I was uh totally
um
I believe that that uh despite
everything we would we would uh we
whatever that meant it would prevail
um
you know
so
so it would be nice if it was the
opposite you know if you if I had
started in a in a really negative place
and as I and then in my in my age now
you know you know what I'm saying if I
was Vindicated in some way and but
unfortunately things things that just
came darker
how do you feel and now about our
potential to prevail
how do I feel now about what our
potential to Prevail attention well you
know
maybe you can beat the Russians I mean
you know maybe ukrainians maybe they can
do it I mean that's not out of the
question
uh God knows but that would be
incredible and that would be kind of the
thing we were dreaming of back then
I mean you know the the forces of evil
beaten down uh I don't know that that's
uh it's not out of the question let's
put it that way and and uh and God knows
you know we we you know it's possible
it's possible and I you know deep down
I'm not sure I believe that's going to
happen on I'm sure how do you feel
I want to hold on to that possibility
you know I also like like you I brought
children in this world and since I
brought children in this to this world I
have to believe that the forces of evil
can be beaten down
um
um I'm going to let our audience go
Michael thank you so much I wish I could
have seen you in person I hope I will
soon but it was lovely to see you even
over soon
I hope to see the whole family again in
krasnogruda yeah that would be that
would be lovely we'll see we'll see but
uh it's lovely seeing you and and this
whole uh this whole conversation has
been gone it's been very good
I don't know we'll see no it was
wonderful thank you so much Michael Take
Care thank you to our audience